before i could even start the video call
i had to create my own little avatar
customize my hair and my t-shirt
and then once i hit go it popped me into
this like virtual space that like
pokemon or something like that
gather is a
very very new startup and they create
these virtual
event spaces and virtual offices that
are as they put it in the metaverse
you know you can get dozens of people
into this one virtual world so it really
just creates this sense of space um this
virtual space as if you were sort of
meeting someone in real life like in a
office or at some kind of conference so
i grew up in bellevue washington the
suburb of seattle like i grew up on
these online math communities but they
were all forums the most that i got to
know these people was through text and
you would meet up for
in-person math camp maybe for one week a
year and a lot of these same people
would be there and that'd be like the
best week of like all of our lives
eventually kind of like got into
programming as that was kind of like
math but applicable to the real life
during college was kind of working on
all sorts of passion projects always
doing it with friends so then come after
college a lot of our closest friends
were moving to different cities and the
status quo is that you just like talk
less with them over time and their
relationship with falter we thought that
was such a shame that you could do much
better we decided to work on like how
can you have high quality relationships
with people
no matter where they are
we tried a ton of different like
experiments that whole year eventually
getting into these ideas of like virtual
worlds with like virtual reality
[Music]
they put on headsets and they were
working in those headsets
in like a virtual office together for
like eight hours a day in 2020 uh vr was
still you know very far away from being
the type of product that's ready for
mass adoption and even today in 2022
that's still very much the case but
it gave them a bit of an inkling that uh
you know there was this high potential
here for these virtual gatherings
[Music]
we didn't meet in real life for the
first year of founding the company or
actually they didn't meet each other so
i knew all of them individually but the
three of the rest of them never met each
other what the pandemic did was it
created the appetite for trying
something like gather
basically the first day that we launched
into the public there was just insane
demand in all sorts of ways like we just
published it as here you can come into
like a virtual times square there's
nothing you could really do in there yet
we got so many emails from people saying
like hey can i run my professional
conference on here or hey like can i run
my wedding on here or i have a virtual
uh immersive theater event like very
very wide range of things uh and we're
like okay we just need to like work as
hard as possible to keep up with all
this it really just kind of took off by
word of mouth it's been used for all
kinds of different things
coca-cola used it for virtual
conferences amazon prime video created a
gather space and it's being used in
smaller scale capacities too for
birthday parties and weddings for rock
concerts
they are already valued at 700 million
dollars by venture capitalists that's
their private market valuation they've
raised in total 77 million dollars from
the likes of sequoia capital
excel
and y combinator which is the
accelerator program that they went
through the point the metaverse is
really about that human connection and
we see things like gather being a very
important communication layer uh one
that builds kind of more community more
camaraderie and and can give you more of
those like kind of serendipitous
interactions that are so important in
physical space
you